sin lugar a dudas bueno agradeciendo la
invitación maría declara estos éxitos
son de gabriel boris y recordemos que el
acuerdo de extracción no había sido
firmado por el ex presidente sebastián
piñera era muy limitado por una parte de
la política chilena y en uno de sus
primeros actos únicos lo que hace es
barrer a puerto y enviarlo al senado que
termina obviamente posteriormente
ratificándolo también lo que tiene que
ver con no solo en la subida importante
de lo que es cuando mínimo sino que
también la discusión respecto a una
pensión el aumento de la pensión y
incluso e incluso que no ha tenido una
ruptura digamos nación abierto de
ruptura por ejemplo con buenas políticas
que vienen de gobiernos anteriores el
gobierno anterior desear que piñera
simplemente una pensión garantizada
universal bueno gabriel moris la elevó
tremendamente haciendo es un acierto
importante y un beneficio para una
ciudadanía que cada día está más en
dificultades en virtud de esta pandemia
pero también de la situación que nos
está golpeando entonces no sólo el
acuerdo de cápsula estirada que también
tuvo el canadá firmar acuerdo perfecto
del océano el presidente boris hoy día
está plasmando una mirada novedosa y un
estilo innovador de lo que es la
centroizquierda en américa latina con
mucho diálogo pero también con multi
mirada de futuro y sus críticos lo
señalan de no tener experiencia
suficiente que ha hecho el presidente
ante retos como la inflación y la crisis
de seguridad de la macro zona sur del
país
sin lugar a dudas activo uno de los
talones de aquiles no ha sido un punto
débil sobre todo en la primera parte del
gobierno pero también hay que ser
honesto distinguir esa experiencia o esa
inexperiencia se refiere más bien a la
coalición gobernante gabriel moris tiene
una importante experiencia de dos
período parlamentario además de lo que
es el liderazgo estudiantil pero
evidentemente y también hay que éste no
son estos la crítica corresponde es
decir hubo muchos nuevos ministros y
díaz que no eran caras conocidas
justamente porque no está haciendo más
bien está siendo apoyado por una de las
coaliciones que anteriormente no tiene
pero él no es de esta coalición es el de
aprueba dignidad por lo tanto este tipo
de dificultades por ejemplo pensaron en
errores comunicacionales importantes por
parte de la ministra del interior ahí sí
así ha habido un talón de aquiles bueno
como lo está respondiendo el presidente
boris incorporando experiencia pues
justamente a partir de aquella parte de
la coalición que vivía lo soporta lo
soporta el parlamento ha tenido el apoyo
de personajes que por ejemplo está muy
bien vinculado a michelle bachelet por
decir uno de los nombres
y a pesar de estos respaldos la
popularidad del presidente boris ha
subido y ha bajado en este último tiempo
como lo que le pase a boris puede
afectar la redacción de la nueva
constitución o si políticamente no son
fenómenos que estén ligados
o al revés como lo que la percepción de
la reacción el órgano rector de la nueva
definición puede afectar a la imagen de
gabriel bonito yo creo que son dos
procesos políticos que no están
vinculados y bien evidentemente tienen
en común el destino de aquí hasta el 4
de septiembre creo que aspecto es la
popularidad de riesgo y en la
popularidad del nuevo borrador de estos
desaciertos que se vieron tanto en la
convención como el borrador pero que
quien más y sobre todo visto que ha
remontado en la expuesta yo creo que lo
que este prospecto de cara al 4 de
septiembre es que se incluyan
positivamente de manera recíproca ante
los procesos